la fée du café de la soupe à et de
montchanin pour racler présents puissent
avoir le choix de pas vu café ou alors
tu t'es d'accord
comme chaque dimanche midi les bénévoles
de l'association main tendue se prépare
pour une nouvelle marotte sacs de
couchage gâteau soupe des biens et des
aliments pour aider les hommes et les
femmes qui doivent affronter l'hiver
sans domicile serge galiano responsable
des maraudes donne un coup de main et
prépare les paniers alimentaires des
maraudeurs il est temps de partir dans
les rues de toulouse
mais avant tout petit coup de téléphone
aux 115 pour prendre les dernières
informations sur les urgences de la
journée
14h30 départ de la maraude symbole de
l'association main tendue le solidari
bus permet d'accueillir les toulousains
dans le besoin pendant quelques instants
histoire de retrouver un peu de chaleur
et de se confier autour d'un plat et
d'une boisson chaude
seulement voilà à partir d'avril le bus
ne pourra plus circuler dans les rues de
toulouse
trop vieux trop polluants il est
considéré comme hors classe en critère
st
[Applaudissements]
ce minibus est vieux il est hors
catégorie et donc à partir du mois
d'avril 2021 nous n'aurons plus le droit
de circuler aux enfants centre ville il
nous sert tout simplement accueillir
donc les gens que l'on croise dans la
rue qui sont sur le trottoir
voilà et qui font quelquefois la manche
aussi et ça nous permet de discuter les
faire entrer un petit peu dans le bus
discute avec eux et est passé du temps
voilà à les écouter
voilà un petit peu à l'écart du bruit
des rues
l'association main tendue peut compter
sur le soutien de ses bénévoles et de
quatre étudiantes chargé de collecter de
l'argent pour soutenir le collectif et
donner une seconde vie aux solidarités
bus
l'occasion pour serge galiano et les
étudiantes de se mettre au point pour
leurs futures actions
nous souhaitions absolument travail avec
un une association qui vient en aide aux
personnes défavorisées aux sans abri à
l'origine la cagnotte elle était pour le
noël solidaire qui tord gagner chaque
année nous voulons récolter 1200 euros
pour les cadeaux qui seront ni serait
bien une centaine de personnes précaires
mais finalement il a trouvé une autre
source de financement et nous avons
proposé d'utiliser cette cagnotte pour
le solidari bus le bus menées entre et
si l'avenir du solidari bus restent en
suspens il ne fait aucun doute que
l'association main tendue continuera son
action pour venir en aide aux plus
démunis dans les rues de toulouse